all right we are recording this is the
reason live stream I'm here with Zach
weismiller hey Zach how you doing hey
good Nick how are you I'm very good and
we are talking with Rob long Our Guest
uh and we're going to be talking he is a
writer uh producer I think maybe a
director as well he's uh we're going to
be talking about the Hollywood strikes
that are coming up and uh part of what's
at uh at issue there has to do with the
effect of AI on uh the creative
Industries in Hollywood and as part of
my research for this I know Rob I'm
friendly with Rob uh but I actually went
to Google bard and I asked the AI
generator there to say who is Rob long
uh and it did a little bit better than
Chachi PT and I I have an account for
chat GPT and they said hey you know uh
chat GPT and they've been cleaning up
their act they say as of my knowledge
cut off date in September 2021 Rob long
is a writer and tele television producer
in Hollywood and of course there in
Hollywood a lot has happened since 2021
so Rob could be you know in the Harvey
Weinstein Suite uh could you just
forward me what it said about so it so I
know that someone has the right answer
to who is right I would love to know
yeah so uh but Bard uh Google which is
free so you know yeah you get what you
pay for but it says Rob long is an
American writer and television producer
in Hollywood uh he's best known for his
work on the long-running television
program cheers for which he received
Emmy and Golden Globe nominations in
1992 and 93. he also created the
television show George and Leo among
others I'm skipping over some addition
to his television work Rob long is the
contributing editor for National Review
as well as a contributor to time
Newsweek International The Wall Street
Journal and the Los Angeles Times he
hosts the syndicated weekly radio
commentary Martini shot and appears
regularly on political commentary shows
and then it editor realizes Rob and it
says Rob long is a talented writer and
producer with a successful career in
Hollywood I don't know why people are
afraid of AI it sounds great he is known
for his sharp wit and ability to create
funny and relatable characters he's also
a respected voice in the political Arena
also me and his Martini his work on
Martini shot is a must listen for anyone
interested in current events so Rob long
uh thanks for talking to the recent live
I
um
I I kind of uh
I kind of want to know more about I
can't help but think that there's a
person in there who said that those
things I want to know that person I mean
how does how does AI know they know me
so accurately I'm just that is that is
literally what I am I'm wondering too
and this is already probably in
production that has been canceled uh by
Netflix but just in generating an AI
question about somebody you probably
create a limited run series I think
that's canceled after the first season
Cliffhanger but
um let's uh let's talk about the
writer's Guild uh strike which I think
is turning 100 days old as we talk
that's right take this on Wednesday I
think it's going live on Thursday but um
you know let's uh uh Zach and I are both
good Libertarians which means we believe
in private sector unionization more iffy
on uh public sector anything that's not
coercive is great rob you wrote a great
story for commentary which doesn't come
up and you're a cowleness and commentary
that should have been in the AI and
you're also on the glop podcast we might
as well get a shout out for that uh the
Glock podcast is you Jonah Goldberg and
John pod Horace right yeah yeah we we
pretend it's about something but it's
really about
kind of reference on uh on wings right I
have to say that that we're the uh that
he's the best but that's only because we
haven't uh had you on that I don't know
about that I suspect that there's a
genuine uh battle
if I met you also created or helped
co-create the uh podcast platformer
online community Ricochet that's right
yeah yeah what what exactly is Ricochet
these days well uh Eric Chase started
the idea was that the internet is a
swamp and filthy and rotten and people
just scream at each other for no reason
and nothing really useful happens and
nobody really develops any deep
relationships or has a good debate
because you know hiding behind whatever
you're hiding behind you get to be in
Troll and so we thought well good
libertarian response to that is if you
if you got to pay a little bit we
started we pegged the mem the monthly
membership to Ricochet we said would be
the price of a grande latte at the
flagship Starbucks in Seattle we would
call them every now and then find out
what it was because the theory was you
know for a call the cost of a cup of
coffee every month you've got skin in
the game and if you get skin in the game
if it's your club and you're a member
you don't want to mess it up and that's
kind of how it's worked it's just had a
hard time growing because for one thing
people do like there is a huge business
in screaming at people anonymously turns
out on Twitter but that's really what it
starts it's a conversation Forum you
join in order to contribute to I mean
you can read it for free but if you want
to contribute and start your own
comments or like go into the member feed
and and meet other people you have to be
a member to be a member you have to pay
a monthly fee
um
but I'm wrong that it was also a podcast
platform well then we decided okay well
in addition to that we should have a
podcast and we so we started the podcast
as a marketing tool we thought well
we'll launch this podcast this is like
this is 2008. all right so this is a
long time ago we'll launch the podcast
um as we're building the site and so
we'll just have these podcast listeners
um who then will be on the the Facebook
um have a Facebook group and then we'll
just when the site's ready you just Port
them right over to the site which we did
um but then we like doing the podcast so
now we do not just our podcast but we
host a bunch of different podcasts and
we have a giant podcast Network and
where we've raised some money into
raising more money to do long-form
podcast reporting so I'm doing one which
should be ready in the Early Autumn
about uh our response to covid and and
what happened and how we treated people
who
uh dissented and did other research and
then we're doing one on the Second
Amendment we're doing one on
a bunch of other things doing one on
China and how we either either gonna uh
um win or not win and what the definite
what the strategies might be our idea is
to keep that tone
um from Ricochet sort of the same which
is lighter
um uh more personal uh and you know no
my rule for this is the same as my role
for show businesses that nobody pays for
homework right so don't give people
homework all right um give them
something fun to listen to and and to
think about and they will do it all
right so I guess we're done here yeah I
don't know yeah I forget where we are
and what we're talking about if we're
done here you could just read the chatbt
description to me again I I've got to go
in there and I've got a change
uh we'll have it summarize the show and
people can just read that and I also
want to point out you know rob you
mentioned that 2008 is a long time ago
and that is true but it's not as long
ago as your two Emmy nominations and
Golden Globe nominal that's very true
you did not win those either right well
you know
um what is
I don't know what winning is what is
winning did I win yeah I feel I have won
yeah as Buzz Aldrin what it's like to
come in second right you know and I
don't ask them don't ask anything really
happen yeah don't ask him if he landed
on the moon because he'll take a shot at
you he will I uh I'm working for it
that's uh uh uh a kind of bucket list
thing I haven't yet done you wrote one
of the reasons where one of the reasons
we're talking to you
uh besides those Golden Globe
nominations in uh you know the pre uh in
the in the first Clinton administration
is uh you wrote a fantastic piece and
this was in uh uh God months ago
for
um commentary magazine about how uh and
now I've lost it because I okay here it
is oh yeah how I became a union man
um and this is uh you're talking about
the prospect this was done in May or or
actually in April before the strike
started you were talking about the
prospect of uh of striking Zach do we
have a a couple of clips from that uh
yeah here we go well yeah I mean you
cheekily described yourself uh as uh
becoming a Bolshevik because of the
strikes so I mean what I'm curious is
you know what are the conditions uh that
the writers are facing that makes you
you know even more sympathetic to the
Union as you then you may have
previously been
well I mean I I wasn't sympathetic to it
in his previous strike I'm a member of
it because I'm you know I'm a writer and
you remember the writer skills you are
and I'm happy to be a member of it and
um but I I thought that the strike we
had in two I think often the uh the
writers engage in kind of loud noisy
defeated self-dramatics they don't
really pay attention to how the business
Works they're not really they don't pay
attention to where their money comes
from uh and the money stream and so they
end up saying a lot of irrational things
and financially you just you have we had
a strike in 2007 2008 and it financially
it's never recovered
um it was not beneficial
um this one's slightly different I mean
this one I there's a bunch of things I
disagree with that the writer skill
seems to think is important that I don't
think are as important but I I I I think
of it this way in the um this is the
umbrella term
that in all of the strikes in the past
and I include that the the the acting
actor strikes and everything the
fundamental theory has been the
fundamental situation has been that you
know Hollywood is run by
um that they're artists right and then
the business itself is run by evil
greedy malevolent but very competent
shrewd business people business men
really yeah um and uh it's really been
an argument about hey we want a piece of
that pie that you have been baking and
so 2007 2008 last strike it was you know
the these evil Wicked Geniuses had
navigated Show Business through uh from
the movie era to the TV era and then
from the TV era to the rerun residual
era and from the re-run residual era to
the VCR rental errand from the VCR
rental area to the DVD rental area
era and they've done such a great job
they were making pots of money and hey
that's some of that belongs to me right
so you're striking because other people
are successful and they owe their
success to you this is and this is just
fundamentally different now it's in fact
it's backwards
the people running show business have
done a terrible job of it they have
failed utterly and some of them are
these names that have been very
successful in the past but are now
utterly defeated can you name a name I
mean Hollywood loves to name names well
pick any any and I I would say anybody
running a studio or network now is a
failure
okay
um uh anyone running a streaming service
right now
uh is very close to a fool
um so the argument isn't isn't that
you've made some money we want a piece
of it the argument is you have it
all up yeah and we don't know how to
unfuck it now before we go to some of
the specific uh uh complaints or or
demands by the Union uh which many of
them sound uh you know like the way
you're talking about it it's clear
um you know the the record industry was
here before publishing was here before
like where there are being you know not
only have there been ongoing
Transformations which you summarize but
then just in the past 10 or 15 certainly
the past 20 years just radical seismic
shifts to all of these Legacy Media
come you know Industries
um and you know it's it it is
sympathetic I mean you're talking to a
bunch of people who are you know or two
people who are writers as well as
everything else and it's the writers
always on some level you know they you
know they we are the most Central to
everything between words and yet we
always get treated you know slightly
worse than the people you know providing
the snacks
um and things like that but
um the uh one of one of the uh main
questions that I kind of have for you is
do writers understand
that by and large nobody outside of
Hollywood gives a about you know
how well they're doing that's one
question and then the uh and I and I
don't mean that like I I think that's
good but then the other question is you
know are are these strikes is the writer
strike is the sag-aftra the the actors
strike
the rhetoric is always that these are
about uh you know the little guy the
person who is barely getting by needs
Insurance uh you know and needs that one
rental payment or that you know whatever
um is that actually accurate or is this
really about you know the the Top Line
people
uh it's sort of that neither
um you're never ever gonna
um
I mean Hollywood is a place where you go
and if you're lucky you're successful
and if you're unlucky you're not
successful and you do something else but
if you're really really really unlucky
you're just successful enough so that
you can keep hanging on year by year by
year by year until you're really too old
and it by that time you realize that
this part-time job you've been having
being a waiter or whatever is actually
is your career and all along you thought
you were a writer a musician or an actor
or whatever
um and and it it in many ways the whole
business is run on that on people who
are just kind of living in a way that
you the rest of us would live but they
have this dream that keeps them alive
and Hollywood is evil it's like an
opiate and it kind of gives you just
enough to make you feel like I'm gonna
be a star on Tuesday and you're not
gonna be a star on Tuesday so that's
never going to change that no matter
what happens if the writers and actors
got every single thing they wanted if
there was no negotiation if the studios
just said yep absolutely check the box
you've got it there would still be a
huge number of people who could say what
people are saying now is hey I lost my
house or I can't afford rent or I I
can't I can't buy a car or whatever it
is that they're complaining about that
that will always be the case if you're a
writer and you're working you will
always have writers uh friends in your
life who will call you up as they always
do and say hey
can I get a freelance episode from you
because if I can get one I can get my
keep my health insurance or hey can I
get can you give me a a line on your
next episode because if I get a line I
get my sag insurance
that happened and it will happen and
we'll that's just nature of show
business right
um this seems to be about something two
things right one thing is that the
massive changes that have occurred and
that nobody knows what the model is
going to look like in the future
uh and the second thing it is is that a
second that's happened is if there's a
massive increase in the number of things
being produced so we all know that's
right we're you know depending on how
much money you spend on streaming
services there's things you'll never
watch them all this TV stuff on there
you'll never see that was produced and
paid for which was a gigantic employment
opportunity for a whole lot of people in
the past five to ten years
um who are now realizing that that was
it that's it's you know the the
streaming service only did six episodes
or only did one season or two seasons of
20 years
um and so the streaming services are in
trouble and and the movie studios are in
trouble and the TV networks are in
trouble and the employees are in trouble
and there's layoffs in every studio and
streaming service around across town and
everybody's trying to rethink everything
and so this is really the first time I
think in Show Business
that everything and everyone
is facing sort of a radical change
um and most of it they brought on
themselves the studios anyway they did
this themselves
um so I know I'm glad you uh painted
that big picture because uh we're gonna
go through some of the specific
negotiating points that uh the writers
are asking for and can hopefully connect
them to what you just laid out there
before we do that though you did mention
something in one of your answers about
uh somebody uh the the people who are
running the studios now are idiots
they're not doing it right how did that
happen uh why are they there was this
just like the tech bubble like uh
created some exuberance and like the
wrong people got up there like what is
your theory as to what happens I don't
know who to blame
um yeah
I mean they're not dumb people they're
very smart people but I think in order
to make blunders of this kind you have
to be very smart dumb people just tend
to you know step on a rake smart people
tend to take a business and destroy it
um
I think it was I mean look I I just use
Netflix as an example right Netflix uh
has did the probably the most
interesting and astonishing Trans
self-transformation in American business
or any industry in the history of earth
right they they were selling they were
renting DVDs and they basically had a
FedEx business where they sent you DVDs
and you're out and then they decided
well we're not going to do that we're
gonna do streaming which is something
totally different and we're not gonna do
just streaming we're actually going to
produce our own content
and they did that because they believed
bizarrely that if they didn't do that
then the studios and the other existing
producers would create their own
streaming services and not give them any
content that was why they did it
which is just dumb I mean it's just a
very dumb thing to think there is no
evidence of that ever and show business
is exactly where
uh you go when you want to buy content
that's all show businesses is people
trying to sell you stuff there would yep
we'll put it this way
the biggest hits on Netflix
starting it off and the biggest hit on
Netflix right now
are off Network reruns all right so the
is the the people watching the office or
cheers or the suits this summer reruns
were big on Netflix but they decided
that no that's not fun and like this is
why I think the problem is is like the
problem for Showbiz for all ever when
people invest or get involved in show
business every ounce of their rational
decision making just evaporates they
just drive in and the palm trees and
something and they go to a party or
whatever they meet a movie star and they
just turn stupid and every single thing
that Netflix has accomplished it could
have accomplished for less money and
better deals and would have the same
number if not greater number of
subscribers and it would also be
watering the garden for future content
if they simply decided that they were
going to rent basically license content
from Studios across town which is what
everyone was doing and making a big
dollar doing it
um instead of trying to be super clever
and smart and think well we can do this
ourselves
um and it's amazing how the how how why
this contagion got uh put it this way
when Apple created iTunes
they didn't know then then run out and
start a lot of bands
right they figured though somebody's
gonna start you know some kid in a
garage they're gonna be plenty of people
who have rock bands we don't have to
start that and that was brilliant right
now it caused some disruption in the
music business and did all sorts of
other things but in many ways it saved
the music business right because there's
no more file sharing
um and then but they still had Apple TV
they they decided they're gonna we're
gonna be even smarter than that which is
amazing too because the I mean you know
a given Apple TV Plus show will have
like an entire you know MGM musical
Heroes of 1939 in it or something like
that I mean what's that morning show I
think it's called or whatever that has
like you know 20 uh you know uh uh I was
gonna say Nobel Prize winners Academy
Award winners multiple Golden Globe
nominees well
et cetera yeah even recent ones Yeah
well yeah so uh if if Netflix is like
the the Exemplar of this sort of over
extended uh
um company that and you said you
described as a contagion that has uh
kind of spread throughout Hollywood it
seems like now this conflict in part is
like well they're trying to to re
they're trying to squeeze what they can
out of it by cutting labor costs and
this is where we can get into some of
the oh yeah there you go from the
negotiation the the this is from the uh
documents that is on that are on the wga
website their their demands and the one
I have highlighted here uh is called
preserving The Writer's room uh so for
pre-green light rooms so rooms on shows
that have not yet to you know uh been
approved to go to air uh minimum staff
of six writers uh including four writer
producers uh and then after the post
green light room would be run one writer
per episode up to six episodes and then
the room kind of scales up after that as
someone who has worked uh in many a
writer room could you tell us uh what is
what is the conflict around writers
rooms why is it so important and where
do you fall in this question
uh well you know it's complicated
because
um as a showrunner and all you ask any
showrunner
um the idea that there's going to be
some regulation about how many writers I
need to hire
uh or how many episodes I have so I know
how to hire or that there's a moment
where your show is green lit
um these days that's a murky moment I
mean maybe they'll make a pilot plus
three I mean this three production order
maybe you you want more episodes or
something like that so as a showrunner I
don't like anybody telling me what I
need
uh certainly nobody The Writer's killed
um and certainly nobody in the studio
um I want to decide what I need and I
want to decide how I do it and I think
there are a lot of showrunners a lot of
writers you think wait a minute I'm the
guy who create this is my family I'm
writing about so I'm gonna write them
all uh that's sort of foolish and you
probably shouldn't write them all but I
don't I would feel very uncomfortable
telling a colleague how many writers
they should have on staff
um the goal for the writer skill the
symbols that but in order to understand
it you have to understand that that the
that
statistically this is never been a
better time to be a writer statistically
there's never been a better time to try
to get a show on the air now it's things
are really good statistically there are
more members of The Writers Guild than
ever before it's actually going to have
a great time right and the idea that
they are in reach of having a major
major
um
uh uh membership base bigger than
they've ever imagined uh because of all
the production but if all the production
means fewer writers then you're not
really gonna harvest the number of WJ
members you want
the underlying theory behind all this is
that
the uh studios are just trying to starve
the creative process and out of it is
coming um you know crappy Productions
doesn't really
um
isn't really I mean
that's sort of the tailwagon the dog I
mean
the
the reason that they don't want to hire
a lot of people on these steps is
because they don't think the shows are
going to work
and they're not planning for these shows
to go for the Long Haul when I was
putting together a staff or a TV show it
was assumed that I was planning
for this show to go 11 years that was
the goal to go 11 years and everybody
wanted to go 11 years I mean everybody I
worked with wanted it to go 11 years the
studio pay me wanted to go 11 years the
network licensing the show wanted to go
11-year everybody wanted this thing to
go 11 years
um now nobody believes that would ever
happen or and they don't even understand
why it should
because if you're making a show for a
streamer it doesn't matter how many
people watch the show that's not the
metric what matters or it as a you know
today it's that's going to change but
as of today those matters like do I have
I encouraged X number of non-subscribers
to subscribe and will those
non-subscribers or who become
subscribers then just get used to paying
it every month
because the old rule was look if I got
you for a year as a subscriber You're
Never Gonna Leave my service and we know
now no that's not true but that was
that's that guided it so the idea of
keeping costs down
and hedging
um
it's rational
um and the idea of like increasing the
staff arbitrarily just as an Employment
Program
seems irrational is this so a kind of
callback to the last writer strike where
um one of the outcomes of that was a
kind of shift to not what are what are
considered non-scripted shows so it's
kind of trying to get back to like
getting Vengeance on the past
um maybe I mean non-scripted aren't
going to be covered by this right I
don't think and it's just there's a
parallel move on the writer's Guild to
sort of declare the editors of those
shows essentially writers of those shows
which I think is legit
um
because they kind of are uh and then
fold them into bring them into the fold
uh I I think it's really um
I think it's more the idea that if
there's gonna be this giant cup you know
fire hose of content
um you're gonna have to you know if
you're gonna make
a million Chryslers
a year right or whatever yeah you're
gonna need yeah I want I want a
machinist on every Chrysler I don't want
you to double The Machinist up and it
really does have that kind of retro
that's ultimately also the problem with
the writer's Guild in general is that um
and the problem with the studios is
they've taken a business that really
works has really worked in the past and
worked a specific way and they've
decided to to to recreate the conditions
that created for GM and Chrysler in 1973
right
that that brings us to another Point uh
that the writer skill raises here uh
trying to stream
there we go
um so you mentioned the metrics like uh
Netflix is kind of notoriously secretive
about how many people watch they don't
release those numbers right uh publicly
um but the writers are asking for
viewership based streaming residuals
um which just means like you were saying
earlier you kind of get paid based on
how many people watch your show
even though from Netflix's point of view
that may or may not be exactly what is
most valuable to them uh What uh you
know some people have gone so far as to
call this the Netflix strike as
shorthand for trying to cope with all
these changes that streaming has wrought
uh what are some of the most important
changes from The Writer's perspective
how they changed the job
well it's also how it's changing even
now right so if you're Netflix you may
not want to tell the writers how many
the pesky irritating writers how many
people watch that show
but you'd have to tell the pesky
irritating advertisers who you're asking
money from uh more and more I mean the
the average ad supported tier of Netflix
is certain is going to very soon
probably within 12 months be the basic
tier of Netflix and if you want to have
no ads on your Netflix you're gonna pay
a big Hefty premium price for it it's
not going to be a disc it's not going to
be a discount
for ads it's going to be a premium for
no ads right because they need that
then they're gonna tell you know you
have to tell Doritos how many people
watch the Dorito spot right that's kind
of how that works and advertisers aren't
going to say well just as long I see you
have a lot of Articles the New York
Times arts section so I guess you it
must be important they're not going to
do that either
um the problem is that that uh there
there are I mean a residual was really
what it sounds like which is the what's
left over you know after you've gotten
paid so all these res in the past
residual
fights and you know wrangles and deal
points were always about uh what happens
in success right because you know that's
the most important thing
um like you've been successful
the show's been working it's been seen
at least twice or three times on network
and now it's a residual payment off
networker rerun now most Pilots don't
get made to a series most series don't
go past a year most you know series that
go past a year may not go past two years
so most things in Show Business Don't Go
the Distance so we were really talking
in the old days about residual payments
religious the things that we're gonna
you know that at the very far end you
know the you know people like Dawn Wells
and right the rest of Gilligan's Island
yeah they are and eventually you know I
mean I could I was trying to find my my
last residual check which is like it's
tiny at this point
um but Netflix doesn't have residuals
for uh for its original program right
because it it it only shows it once you
can watch it a million times if you want
to
um and what did residual love it's a
residual of the fee you got paid up
front can I ask though is there I mean
does does a Netflix or you know we're an
Amazon or a studio now that we're out of
like the old model does it pay certain
writers better because of their
reputation or their track record or you
know because it's good to work with them
and is a way around this I mean I I get
the idea that it's like very frustrating
to say you know what my show was like
ranked number one or number two on
Netflix for a month and I got paid the
same or less as a friend of mine who did
a show that like nobody watched at all
um but does it do the producers or or
the people who pay for this don't they
fold that kind of they make some kind of
calculation into that at the beginning
especially if they're not saying you
know what uh you know here's here's a
flat rate and then if we reach this
level you know we're going to give you a
royalty or something like that well it
When anybody discovers how you get paid
in Show Business yeah um they usually
either get confused or angry or both or
they just go right back to your point
which is they don't just give a
right
um because you get paid in
at least three or at least two but
sometimes three different ways to do it
to be right on a show and we're talking
about anything that hap whatever happens
it's anything not a feature film
you get paid as your whatever your level
writer level is and that's the number
set by the marketplace in your agent and
your manager whatever so I'm a producer
show runner so I get paid a lot per
episode
whatever episodes I work on I get paid
but if I write an episode I mean it's
written by I get the written by credit I
get paid whatever the Guild minimum is
everyone gets paid the Guild minimum
because your value as a scriptwriter uh
on a TV series is not really as high as
your value as a member of the staff a
creative member of the staff and and
when you're running a TV show you'll
assign scripts to staff members usually
starting at the lowest ranked up and
then they go off for into their office
for a week and then they but they're
always in the office or if they're at
home but whatever they're still doing
their job on that week's episode right
that's the most efficient way to do
these things so you have all these
different income streams and they're
separate residuals and all this other
stuff is based on Guild minimums that's
what the art that's what the The Guild
goes on strike for minimums
um
not my producer fee not your supervising
producer fee or whatever it is that's
going to be set by the marketplace now
what usually happens in these
negotiations what happened in 2007 and
will happen this time is whatever
agreement the studios and streamers make
the producers make to raise minimums
and they will make agree they've already
made some offers but they're going to
have to move it up and they'll move it
up
they end up and you know it happens in a
room they go in a room and they are in a
conference room and they they agree to
something and they get together and they
go in the elevator down to their cars in
the parking garage and as they're
walking to the parking garage without a
doubt what happens is all the studios
say well listen
if we go over here on the minimums if we
give them their 22 bump or whatever it
is on minimums then we all have to agree
that after this strike we're given all
these producer people like Rob 22 25
haircut on their fee right which of
course is collusion and illegal but it's
what they do and and magically when the
strike is over all the agents are making
you know making deals to try to get
people back to work and they just notice
that all over town everyone is getting a
pay cut because that's
how it works that's you know that's how
you get the money back you try to get
the money back
um
it's you know sometimes writers are
surprised by that as they were in 2007
when the deal when the strike was over
and they realized they were they every
gain that went to minimums they were
going to pay for in reduced fees
uh but that that is kind of how Show
Business Works where you're kind of
trying to get as many different ways
many different revenue streams for one
project as you can
you know I know a showrunner who like uh
made sure he wrote the theme song
when he created a show so that he got
paid for that too like a little bit you
know like a thousand dollars every
episode and you know 25 bucks 30 bucks
every time it's on reruns it like starts
to add up you go to the you go to the
mailbox at the end of the quarter and
you get some you know you can get 100
200 000 if you you got enough little
little little checks on the way
it seems like uh what partially what
you're saying is that the subscription
model that Netflix pioneered is not
really going to work long term or is
like at a Breaking Point uh are you
saying that
if at the end of this negotiation that's
going to push it over that breaking
point and that is why it's going to you
know this idea of you just paid eleven
dollars a month and get to see unlimited
content without ads that's over
at the end of the strike pretty much is
that your prediction well I mean it
eventually will be I mean that that has
never ever worked
it show business for 100 Years of show
business you have never made money just
selling content it has never worked you
have always needed to have a movie
theater and the movie theater rents the
movie for a little bit and kind of holds
some back and skim some cash off it you
got you know every student got ripped
off by movie theaters for the first 20
years of Showbiz 25 years 30 years of
the movie business because it was all
cash and they would actually stew this
thing they actually did this in the 20s
I think the 20s and 30s they would send
pinkertons the studios and Pinkerton
detectives to a the seven o'clock show
and they would go and they buy a ticket
for the seven o'clock show at 6 30 and
they would buy a ticket for the seven on
the same show at 7 15 and would match
the number on the ticket and they would
sort of randomly audit Studios oh
theaters I mean to see how many how how
much of the skim they were losing and a
certain amount they expected but greater
than that they complained
but Dennis the theaters weren't really
making money on the ticket necessarily
they're making some money on the ticket
but they were going to sell you a you
know now they sell you a Diet Coke for
nine dollars yeah
um that's everyone's I mean for this
system to work everyone has a little bit
of the piece of your thing and has their
hand in your pocket you got their hand
in their pocket and that is actually the
most efficient economic environment
ever and like the irony for me is that
this environment the the what show
business actually worked
was the dream the fantasy dream of every
Silicon Valley techno you know utopian
in the early 2000s if you I would go up
to Silicon Valley and they would have
like on panels which is their people in
Silicon valleys I've discovered
Libertarians and Silicon Valley people
have panels about every week and you go
on a panel and uh they would you talk
about Show Business and stuff and then
people tell you we're gonna We that that
business needs to be disruptive and they
would describe the ideal Tech world
right where it's like kind of uber you
know it's everybody distributed content
distributed uh effort you don't really
work for a company you're kind of on
your own and that is actually how Show
Business worked
it was perfect for them and yet the
minute they came the first thing they
did was what everybody does which is
they built a little you know a magic
Fortress in the sky Netflix had it all
figured out but then they thought well
wow what if we make some because I would
like to go to the award shows who
doesn't want to make movies I know I
mean this is the plot of a million you
know different movies about making
movies right you get the dentist you
know out on Long Island put in 25 Grand
because he wants to hang out with stars
that's actually literally true yeah yeah
that's the Silver Screen partners that
was the the that was the financial
vehicle that saved Disney in the 80s was
something called Silver Screen partners
yeah well and we'll get to Disney in a
little bit but you know it's kind of
fascinating Disney had a massive loss
last year and people have forgotten that
in the late 70s and early 80s Disney was
a leading indicator of how the American
economy had just completely the bed
right and was about to go out of
business so you know the more things
changed more they kind of stay the same
uh Zach did you want to uh show the AI
um yeah this was the last uh this was
the last negotiating point that I had
highlighted uh about uh AI which we
alluded to at the beginning of the
stream
um regulate the use of artificial
intelligence on MBA covered projects a I
can't write or rewrite literary material
can't be used as Source material uh this
is you know this is the part uh which is
a concern for both the writers and the
actors as we'll see here in moment and
it's also where I start to raise my
eyebrow a bit because while I can see
the need for renegotiating terms with
all the changes you've laid out
um it does seem like you're potentially
cutting off a what could be an
incredibly productive tool before its
full power to even be real like been
realized the ability to use AI not to
replace human creativity but augment it
what is right your reaction to the AI
components of the writer's angst well
you know I mean
after Nick's introduction I love AI
that's fantastic it's very flattering
it's very flattering
um my glib response was when I hear
writers complain about AI I can't say
they're worried about AI is like wow how
bad are you like that you're worried
that A robot's gonna change it I suspect
AI is going to be used by writers
more than it's ever used by a studio
or it's going to be used by writers who
are in the exalted level of writer which
is something that rarely comes up in
these negotiations I mean
I can easily see a showrunner aiing a
bunch of outlines I mean when I guess
when AI isn't you know weird
um I can easily see that um I don't know
if I would I don't know if I mean I
write comedy so I if you if you someone
showed me AI once at one time made a
joke that wasn't stupid
uh and wasn't what I would consider to
be a fireable offense that the writer I
was paying made that joke
um then I guess I'd be a little bit more
worried uh see now you're getting to the
tension between the uh the show Runners
and the staff writers which I know
you've written about before where it's
like are are we in solidarity or is
there actually a hierarchy here and AI
might be useful to the showrunners and a
threat yeah yeah but it also might be
helpful to the writer who is stuck and
is trying to generate story ideas I
think it's going to be very very helpful
if you're on a legal show or a medical
show or you're on one of those shows or
one of those you're doing a project
where someone has to say well that's
well that's you know and then that's
yeah
the syndrome
how did they come up with letters of
transit in Casablanca which don't exist
but yeah they invented it they invented
it right right or like every episode did
you ever see uh the TV show it was good
show friends of mine did it and it was
really great and Hugh Laurie was
terrific in the show House yeah it's
like every every week you got to come up
with some only house can figure it out
and you gotta have a doctor and in fact
you know I don't know that seems like
really hard like AI perfect at the risk
of uh going down a rabbit hole that will
never come out too late yeah uh but an
old colleague of mine had reason a guy
named Chuck freund wrote on the old
banacheck show oh wow series a
short-lived series of locked room
Mysteries and George Peppard yeah
um he said like by the end of the first
season people were shooting themselves
because it's like where can you come up
with another locked room that's
improbable but we have a clip here
speaking of AI uh from Brian Cranston
who I loved as Tim Whatley on Seinfeld
he's great as the father on Malcolm in
the Middle oh he's breaking so great in
it yeah a fantastic actor he also played
LBJ a and a play uh Zach you want to cue
this up where he's he's he's got a
message to the head of the Disney Studio
and all the other suits
uh we've got a message for Mr Iger
[Applause]
I know sir that you look through things
through a different lens
we don't expect you to understand who we
are
but we ask you to hear us and beyond
that to listen to us when we tell you we
will not be having our jobs taken away
and giving to robots
we will not have you take away our right
to work and earn a decent living
thank you
and lastly and most importantly we will
not allow you to take away our dignity
[Applause]
Robert how do you how do you respond to
that well first of all I love Bryan
Cranston so much uh
and I I mean I'm a writer so I'm like
yeah I'm making jokes in my head like
really take away your dignity your your
you you play Make Believe for a living
let's let's but but I I think as an
actor
it is much more worrisome and I don't
think it's a good replaced by a robot
it's just that you're not going to have
to pay Brian Cranston because you got
Brian Cranston already in on your
servers and you can kind of make Brian
Cranston do and say whatever you want to
make Brian Cranston do and say and it is
true that the the Studios have been
planning that because the one thing they
wouldn't back down on the reason sag it
out I think one of the reasons went out
um is because they said all right well
for you know big name actors would be
one thing but if you're just a
background artist meaning an extra what
we call atmosphere
once we get you
on you know whatever we've modeled you
digitally we can use you in anything
forever
for free now do we know that that is the
the contract or the rules that are being
discussed because I've read that that's
a misrepresentation yeah we're talking
about this particular shoot but yes that
is the yes they they have clarified that
but if you're a if you're a writer
you kind of feel like uh you know what
you're you're you're you're you're
you're gonna need a writer to fix the AI
it may be a first draft but you're gonna
have to pay a writer and we'll just just
change the minimum so you had to pay me
more and even though it's a second draft
based on an AI draft which is never
going to be right just that Executives
don't want to they don't want to read a
script let alone type in
how to write it I don't know most
Executives don't read right so they
don't even you know so but an actor is
different an actor is fundamentally
different and they I understand why
they're afraid there's you know there's
a in the new season of black mirror
there's an episode uh that is built
around this concept that uh you know
Salma Hayek is her her likeness has been
captured and she's being used in a in a
in a show kind of not quite against her
will because somewhere deep in the terms
of service she had agreed to all of this
There Are Rules already in laws against
using the likeness of people
um you know so it seems and again it may
be maybe not for uh an extra background
artist but for somebody like Brian
cramps and that seems unlikely
um is it I mean like when I hear
Cranston you know who delivers all of
those lines fantastically but yeah I'm
listening to like hey let's go break
those looms you know he was on 44th
Street let's just go over to the Garment
District and you know there's a bunch of
selling machines that are really you
know screwing up how you know how much
more money we could make per race or
something like that I don't know you
know it just seems so far-fetched
um as to be kind of risible as a main
focus of of anxiety I mean of anxiety I
think there's a lot of anxiety because
your industry is going through a massive
restructuring and as you were saying rob
nobody knows how this is going to play
out in any meaningful way but like that
particular concern
strikes me as odd you know theater you
know actors have been around since you
know before Christ
yeah and they're probably going to be
around after he comes and uh you know
and wasn't an actor who killed Lincoln
let's let's let's yeah right yeah um uh
I I hear you I I understand I think I
understand what you're saying I would
say there are probably two
um
there's sort of two levels here and the
top level anxiety is something you also
see in the writers which may not be
connected to the immediate threat but is
sort of
is indicative of the general anxiety
which is that these all of this these
Technologies are designed to remove what
I do which has always been subjective
and was already incredibly risky
um and to take me entirely out of this
out of the out of the the business right
um and then on a for the actors on a
fundamental or a closer level
um part of especially I mean any actor
but I mean a big actor like Brian
Cranston but anybody else is that when a
project goes over
or when a project needs reshoots which
they all do they got to pay you
by the day
and for some people if you're at Brian
Cranston level that's a whole lot of
money that's actually that's a big part
of it could can be a big part of your
annual income and if you're a mid-range
actor they need you back to reshoot this
or reshoot that or whatever they need
you back for
and if they don't have to bring you back
if they can kind of within the context
even the context is one title the same
title you know whatever that movie was
or project was you're still there they
don't have to pay you
for additional work that they've created
in the box that isn't effect work but is
in fact just error correction or
whatever
um
that's a bad road for the actor that's a
bad road to go down if you're an actor
and that's something you probably want
to protect so it isn't quite something
like so much that you're breaking again
it's it's completely understandable that
actors and writers uh you know want to
get as much money as they can for the
work that they do I you know that but
then when you pull back a little bit it
just seems like other industries that
have automated other industries that
have you know used technology they
figure out a way
um I mean and it seems like Hollywood
you know for lack of a better term is
the last industry that is going to be
like you know what you've seen Bryan
Cranston already we're going to give you
uh uh you know a fake Brian Cranston and
you're gonna love it
um you know because and if you can if
you can replace Brian Cranston and
Breaking Bad with Brian Cranston from a
Mac Book
then maybe you know maybe there's not as
much uh Magic going on or I I just
strikes me as it's a it's a heavy ask to
you know regular people who just are
watching TV or going to movies who are
paying more every year
Etc you know right like you know but the
important thing is that Brian Cranston
get that extra check
um but that's what's fair in the world
well what's fair is if you I mean the
difference is that if you were making
you know if you're a famous sweater
Knitter you know
then you may not like the loom because
it makes sweaters right a lot cheaper
and faster than you can knit them but
you and you really can't say much about
it but you can say if someone sell if I
make a sweater and a loom and I say this
is a nicolespie
yeah you have every right to say no way
no way that's not Nicholas I mean
Gillespie's the guy who knit the sweater
and I didn't hit that sweater right and
so this isn't really anti-technology
it's more like okay you can make you can
you can make a movie now and ai's a fake
person and it'll probably look pretty
good what you can make your own movie
star if you want you just can't call
that movie star Brian Cranston yeah well
I think I mean certainly from a
Libertarian point of view that makes
subtle sense because then we're talking
about fraud or misrepresentation and
there's no moral issue there but I also
I I suspect that they'll be an aesthetic
issue where it's like people you know
people will want the real Brian Cranston
they'll want the authorized edition of
then they'll have to they should pay and
Brian Cranston should make whatever the
the absolutely can but but I say also
and even now it's the studios and the
streamers that have brought us to this
position right because they're the ones
that have created so much content in
this ridiculous War they're having for
streaming services that makes no
Financial sense
Financial moves they have done and the
only way and I said it hurt it kills me
as a writer but the only way
um for them to distinguish a prod one
project from another is with a star like
a recognizable face that's how you get
people to watch so Brian Cranston stuck
and every other act good actor stock
went way up as it should have because
he's got something special now you can't
say that you can't say to people well
we're going to take that special thing
away no you created the conditions that
have created this now you have to live
with your own bad uh your own Bad
Business modeling let's uh speaking of
business models can I just register
by one uh worry uh with it because I I
can totally understand where Brian
Cranston is coming from and especially
some of the people who aren't at Brian
cranston's level who might be afraid
that their image is going to get
exploited over and over again
but what what I worry about with um kind
of an overreach would be that Hollywood
I think sometimes has a tendency to draw
boundaries or or gatekeep a little bit
too tightly with whether it comes to the
use of new technology or intellectual
property
these are all tools for creating new
things and if you're going to gatekeep
access to those tools you're inevitably
going to make it harder for the upstarts
the people who don't have a lot of
institutional backing to
uh to to use them
um and you know there's been a lot of uh
fights over the years uh to expand fair
use protection of re repurposed material
that's a fight we've fought alive
because we're in documentaries and so we
will uh you know be commenting on other
material and then you'll get you know
take down notices and Hollywood's been a
major Force against that so that that is
what I worry about with kind of over
defining like what is AI like what is
generated by AI what is like you know my
image is if it's if it's sort of based
on an image of another person but it's
not really them is that going to be
covered by this prohibition those are
kind of like the the Margin Call type
cases that I guess I I worry about the
most I don't know how it's all you know
going to resolve
um and and there's certainly arguments
on both sides but but that that's kind
of what looms large when I think about
it yeah
I have a solution
okay
because
um
if you go back to the glory years right
when there was more independent film
those true independent film when when is
this well you know pick it you know
sometime in the you know late 80s we'll
say 80s right so okay
despite the tail end of the studio
system kind of fell apart
um I mean you know from the 1920s on a
block booking went and the FEDS got
involved and then TV and then the fed's
gotten re-involved where they had the
financial interests and syndication
rules and then that kind of like you
know they they sort of be deregulated
and sort of around the 80s people
started to like you could really make a
lot of money with an independent film
and you could really make a lot of money
as a small Studio
um an unaffiliated small Studio by the
way uh
that that is the solution
for innovation in almost every industry
but definitely innovation in show
business or at least to keep the doors
open or more open for change the what
what this the irony is that the the the
the very people who seem to understand
that sort of in their DNA which is the
Techno to technology people from Silicon
Valley the minute they got into the 310
212 213 area code they completely threw
it away and they decided oh I want to
have a vertically integrated studio with
both my exhibitors and my studio doing
the same thing I want to eat what I kill
and nobody in show business has ever
made any money eating what they kill you
eat what that guy kills a little bit and
you give him some of your stuff and
everybody kind of gets rich and they
didn't do that and if they did that
um we would not be here in this position
Let's uh turn to a clip uh that features
Alan Rock the actor he sure ran for a
long time uh you know we loved him in
Ferris Bueller we saw him most recently
in succession and he has something to
say about the studio the suits the heads
technology capitalism uh let's run this
clip
kings and queens and Emperors and now
it's captains of industry and they think
that the world and everything on it and
in it everything in the air and in the
ocean belongs to them and they think
that human beings were not of their you
know socio-economic class are just
another natural resource
mostly to be managed to be utilized may
be exploited but mostly to be managed
because they always say stuff like those
people they're asking for too much well
we're not we're not asking for too much
we're asking for what's fair this isn't
this isn't about the movie stars this is
about the journeyman actors the
journeyman writers the people that that
make the thing go the wet dream for uh
some big shots is like just hire one
star and have the AI do everything else
you know well we're not gonna allow that
foreign
oh um
I mean we're not going to allow it I
mean yeah I mean if it if it could
happen it'll happen right if it can
happen that's exactly what will happen
but the solution to I mean you would
this will not surprise you Nick that I
think the solution to this is more
capitalism
right that the problem we have and I
actually feel like things go in Cycles
right so you had a deregulation cycle
that kind of encouraged these Behemoth
Studios and networks to join and you
know we have a you know uh Comcast is a
giant cable network and a studio and a
TV network and a streaming service
of the Pentagon as well at this point it
it I hope not because it is an
incompetent conglomerate and should not
exist definitely is okay right right I
mean it should not exist and it will be
busted up and capitalism is what's going
to bust these things up and when they're
bust and I don't think I mean in the old
days it was that the federal Regulators
you know Richard Nixon said I don't like
these TV networks they hate me so I'm
going to make sure they can't own the TV
shows they put on because if they could
do that then they are really really rich
um now what have you had he just let
them do it they would have gotten really
really rich for like a day and then
really really poor for like a year which
is what's about to happen to all these
big companies which is why they're even
now today talking about what pieces of
their of their business they're gonna
sell right um and when they sell them
all uh everything in Show Business will
be better for the next 15 years until
they put them all back together again as
they do would you could you describe
briefly and we have a clip of uh that
we'll show after this but Rob what is
the experience of anti-capitalism in
Hollywood uh because on the one hand you
know rhetorically a lot of movie stars a
lot of writers a lot of producers a lot
of Studio heads are anti-capitalists
even as they are phenomenally successful
business people and you know good at
marketing and self-branding and all of
that stuff but what it what is it like
as being somebody who is you know on the
right politically I think you call
yourself a conservative or a maybe a
conservatorian Libertarian conservative
whatever but like you like characters
yeah you you like like markets you like
Freedom you like people being able to
kind of innovate and things like that
what's what's the you know the felt
experience of anti-capitalism for you in
Hollywood
well I mean
I don't know
it's kind of the same reason that people
don't like capitalism in general it's
they don't like the uncertainty of it
that the question you have to ask
yourself with capitalism is what I
rather go for the uncertainty here
change disruption all sorts of things
you know rational economic acting
or would I rather cling to something
that I know and is
um
safe and if you're at the very top of
any organization you you prefer to cling
to something that's safe capitalism the
way you and I understand it I think is
dangerous right we really had capitalism
we wouldn't have uh Goldman Sachs or we
wouldn't have JP Morgan Chase we
wouldn't have these giant uh regulatory
capture scenarios across the board
um
so if you're a movie star and you kind
of think well I mean I know you have
giant ego and you think you're a genius
but there's always a voice inside your
head that says wait a minute
I know that I'm lucky because I almost
didn't go to that audition or I didn't
really want to be in that project that
made me the big whatever it is right so
you're not really crazy about
rational
economic chaos
creative destruction he liked the idea
of there being some kind of somebody
some some people in charge and you can
hear that in the in the arguments made
by you know Brian Cranston and Alan Ruck
the idea that there are these malevolent
Evil Geniuses who have a plan they're
twirling their mustache up there with
the league of super villains and if we
let them let them have their plan
they're going to succeed right but the
truth is that they and that may have
been true in 2007 I think but those same
actors that by the way they are pretty
much many cases the same actors
um I mean in the corporate actors
um have utterly failed
let's look at one of those uh actors who
has utterly failed and this is Robert
Eiger Mr Iger
um I love the false decorum by the way
when people on strike are like Mr Iger
you know et cetera but uh let's run the
clip of Robert Eiger because we've been
talking about this from you know kind of
okay the actors and writers are kind of
you know or I'll say I find them a
little bit annoying uh but you know the
studio heads are equally obnoxious and
by the way Bob Iger is who that is who
Cranston and uh Rucker both pretty much
talking directly specifically talking
about yes so let's here's Robert Eiger
uh beleaguered chairman of Disney we're
in the midst of a writer strike and very
likely it would seem to have a actor's
strike how is that going to impact
things and what are your expectations
there
well I think it's very disturbing to me
I you know we've talked about disruptive
forces on this business and all the
challenges that we're facing and the
recovery from covid which is ongoing
it's not completely back this is the
worst time in the world to add to that
disruption there's a level of
expectation that they have that is just
not realistic and they are adding to a
set of challenges that this business is
already facing that is quite frankly
very disruptive they're not being
realisticated I know they're not I
respect their right and their desire to
get as much as they possibly can in
compensation for their people I and I
completely respect that I've been around
long enough to understand that Dynamic
and to appreciate it but you also have
to be realistic about it with a business
environment and what this business can
deliver it is and has been a great
business for all of these people and it
will continue to be even through
disruptive times
I I wish they had pulled back so we
could see that he is standing on like
little children
amount of skulls yeah but how um so you
know Iger uh and Zach you had the number
we'll we'll show it in a bit but how
much did Disney lose uh in 2022 it was
uh 100 million yeah uh 401 million
dollars
um so he uh you know he and he came back
to Disney so he's you know he's kind of
on the hot seat but Rob what do you what
do you how do you respond to something
like that
well look you know the irony here is
that he is the smartest guy in Show
Business really I mean he's a very smart
guy
um and his uh company is just too Giant
and he started Disney plus and he stood
enough
um
he did a lot of dumb things and he's
right that if you believe that
if you've done this terrible job running
these big media companies
and you're looking at your you know
quarterly earnings or your annual
earnings you're looking at the future in
the future competition and how much it's
going to cost you to keep feeding your
machine for content for 11 a month and
you don't have any pricing power they
don't have any pricing power these
people
um
they're in a business they've never been
in before
consumer product business that's what a
person service is they don't make
consumer products they make TV shows
right they're not making Fritos they're
making TV shows
um they have no there's no experience in
this business and the business is
kicking their ass
um but if you insist that that's the
business you're in yes of course it's
incredibly meddlesome and Troublesome
and disruptive and unrealistic for the
writers and the actors to ask you to do
something else because you're like Hey
listen it's like you know we've driven
the car into a ditch stop you know I
don't have time to like get you a
cheeseburger or whatever it is right but
the driving it into the ditch was the
problem the problem isn't now that you
know you guys aren't on our side they
haven't offered any you know notice
these they never offer you like shares
in the company you know they don't do
that they're not they're not really
offering to make you a stakeholder in
the business so
you know he's smart but I I I there is
no solution for these people even if
even if somehow they it turns out that
the studios strike a deal that they
believe they can then sell to the
shareholders is like a good deal there
is no future for these companies except
to be to break themselves up and they
will it sounds you know while you were
talking it reminds me a bit of the uh
airline industry which goes through
these cycles of booms and busts and
where right smaller Airlines buy each
other and they become bigger because
they're going to have economies of scale
and market share and then they could
dictate you know they have pricing power
and it never quite works out that way
and then occasionally you'll get like
years ago United the employees are like
okay well you know we're gonna buy it
because that way we'll own the company
we're a part of and that they did that
they were like we don't know how to run
an airline we don't want to and they
tried to sell it back Etc so maybe we're
going through one of these Cycles Zach
let's talk um you have some slides about
just like looking at the big picture of
uh you know what you know how's it how's
it working out for Studios that kind of
support a lot of what Rob is talking
about here yeah so we mentioned Disney
posting a negative 401 million dollar uh
loss in 2020 to Netflix uh you'll see
here you know Netflix Sony both uh
uh down uh profit-wise Warner Brothers
NBC Universal Paramount posted modest in
cream there profit margins for 2022 uh
the writer's Guild provided this
historical graphic uh which you see you
know billions uh tens of billions in
operating profits for the the big
companies over the years although they
also can see the 2022 in particular was
a rough year uh for the industry
um this just shows the uh executive pay
for all the big Studio Chiefs
um and you know in in the hundreds tens
to hundreds of Millions for some of them
uh most many of them uh did take a pay
cut in 2022 although you know still
living
only at about 20 million uh yeah well
you know I already built a business
Rob can we go back to that real quick
yeah can you know Rob one of the things
that you hear again and again uh you
know from you know say the Allen rux of
the world is that it is obscene Aria
Manuel who is part of the leading you
know he's the brother of Rahm Emanuel
he's a liberal Democrat if not a
progressive Democrat he has made uh you
know in the past five years he's made
346 million dollars and Alan Ruck says
that is obscene that is wrong he doesn't
deserve to make that much money is Alan
Ruck is Alan Ruck right no he's wrong
area Emanuel built a business it's his
business he built it he's not like it's
a everybody who pays by the way it's a
business built on fees right you know
the business itself was a talent agency
he's got a lot of other pieces of pieces
to it now but it started as a talent
agency people willingly and get engaged
in a contract with Arie Emanuel because
he was a passionate and great talent man
challenge agent representative and they
gave him a portion of their earnings and
he worked for them he built that
business Patrick weitzel's on the bottom
of that Patrick's another partner at WME
and he he did that it's like no of
course he deserves it that that's not I
mean and lumping him in with some of the
sort of factotums there is it doesn't
seem fair uh I would say and I say that
somebody who's not represented by Airy
at all but but I he built a business he
deserves it he earned that money I'm not
I don't I don't
it when the argument becomes about uh
people getting rich and they shouldn't
be getting rich you know that the
they've lost the threat of the the
argument really should be
um you're not going to pull this
business out of a ditch by giving me a
pay cut and by removing uh income
streams from me you're gonna still have
to live up to the standards of paying me
for resid my either my residuals in my
image or my residuals in my writing and
you have to figure out another way to
pull your company out of the ditch and
the way to do that is I keep saying over
and over again is just simply make it
smaller like you find somebody to buy
this if every single one of those
companies you had up there
broke itself into pieces of exhibiting
and
Studio
um like a content creator and then a
contract content exploiter
it would be like the golden years again
and everyone and the idea the fear there
is that okay well nobody will sell me
the No No studio will sell me their
content right that was the net big
Netflix fear which is just completely
ludicrous that just there's just no
evidence for that at all and there's so
much counter evidence to it
Netflix's own ratings or that like and
and creating a a lucrative back end
which is what we're talking about for uh
for content is something that's in the
is benefits the whole environment
everyone does better
do you think that's uh are you
optimistic that is a likely outcome here
for the future of the industry because I
mean one interesting aspect of this go
around with the actors is that sag-aftra
has already issued some waivers to some
of the smaller independent production
companies is that kind of how it starts
to break apart that that really these
smaller maybe more Nimble players are
going to be able to move forward while
the big ones are kind of stuck in the
mud
it breaks apart because the shareholders
eventually wake up
I mean the entertainment business is a
very great very very good place to go
and for individuals to get extremely
rich
it is not a good place for shareholders
to get rich shareholders need to learn
that lesson about every 15 20 years but
they do learn it and there'll be some
activist shareholders some whoever the
latest is that's in some giant
hedge fund who's going to like oh yeah
you're speaking of uh Catholic nuns
right yeah probably right the same ones
who go to Exxon Mobil meetings show up
right now it'll be somebody has fun guys
who's going to make trouble for Sherry
Redstone or make trouble for somebody
and say why do you own this stuff you're
failing at it you're failing at your
streaming service you're failing at your
studio sell it is there any is there any
indication that somebody like Reed Hayes
thinks that Netflix is kind of getting
that message or the or the leaders at
Amazon where you know there it becomes
even more unclear you know uh I've read
that over half of American households
are our Amazon Prime households that
throws off a lot of money Prime video is
one of the ways that you keep people
being Prime households so maybe they
don't really care how many people are
watching or you know and they have yeah
but that's a problem apple and Amazon
don't care right yeah
here this is the subscriber base for
Netflix from 2013 to present uh we're
you know closing in on 250 million paid
subscribers worldwide so yeah you do
have to think like even if uh things
they're struggling right now that's
that's a lot of people uh there's got to
be a way to figure out how to turn that
around right well but but not not if
you're spending money the way they spend
money on content but if for this Slide
the the terror on that slide is the
first quarter of 2020 of 2022.
because that is the first quarter that
the subscriber growth I think I'm it was
definitely first quarter so maybe I'm
looking yeah no you're right that's the
first quarter that subscriber growth
didn't flatten it didn't slow it went
down yeah and the rule was that this
that will never happen it'll just slow
and Plateau they called it and then they
discovered that the people who had
people who gave up Netflix
right they weren't the people you expect
to the people who got it
in December of 2021 because they wanted
to watch movies over the holidays or
they got it because they were you know
in 2020 they were they were it was
during the pandemic they were all home
the people who gave up their Netflix
membership in the first quarter of 2022
were people who've been subscribers to
Netflix for two plus years which was not
supposed to be possible
that the whole model was built on the
fact that once you do it you're not
going to check your credit card bill
anymore you're not even going to know
what that is is that what the hell is
whatever it is but they didn't that
didn't happen which of course anybody
anybody at like Procter and Gamble or
the Frito-Lay Corporation would have
said you know that's not going to work
right that's not how consumers buy
um but these guys have no map no no
experience in that so they had no idea
um so but my long my short answer to
your question Nick is that no I I they
should I mean if you look at all of the
Netflix you know literature and the
stories around Netflix always they're
hyper rational kind of nice yeah they
have like data analytics and for in
through employees too like you know Hey
listen you were employee number three
but you no longer fit into the system so
you're like you self-fire yourself you
think this is kind of a cult right a
cult of rational actors right and yet
the minute they touch Show Business
Corey Feldman you know yeah franchise I
gotta step it out because we're going to
turn this around let's look at the um uh
you know Rob this actually relates to it
too so you know part what you're arguing
is that like the Behemoth that have
become contemporary Studios or
entertainment complexes are too too fast
they're Empires that can no longer
maintain themselves because they don't
know what they're doing they don't know
how to do it well but when we go back to
content I've heard you argue and I think
this is genuinely interesting
um you know that it's also odd that at
this moment uh when everybody needs a
hit people in Hollywood are almost
religiously uh you know conscientious
objectors against reaching the kinds of
mass audiences that they once coveted
um and we want to run a clip uh from
Roseanne which reboot the reboot of
Roseanne which is like basically the
most successful broadcast reboot and
certainly in recent memory
um came out in 2017
um let's let's look at a clip from this
and talk about why Hollywood doesn't
want to make giant hits anymore
she promised that she would get along
and knowing the both of you I'm guessing
you're the one keeping this Feud alive
what's up deplorable
[Applause]
oh yeah first let's say grace Jackie
would you like to take a knee
[Applause]
dear Lord thank you for this food
and for bringing our son DJ home safe
from Syria
but most of all Lord
thank you for making America great again
mom no it's okay Darlene how could you
have voted for him Roseanne he talked
about jobs Jackie he said he'd shake
things up
I mean this might come as a complete
shock to you but we almost lost our
house the way things are going have you
looked at the news because now things
are worse not on the real news oh please
so you know this came out in 2017
Roseanne's character is a trump voter
and Trump supporter her sister Jackie is
you know wearing a hat is uh
Hillary Clinton supporter
um yeah you know why did this show do so
well and why aren't there more of these
shows
um I don't know I I can't answer the
second question because it's a giant
mystery to me and there's a there's a
corollary to that also in the feature
side
uh yeah and just to put the before you
get into it I'll just uh read for the
people listening with the slide that we
just pulled up showing that the first
two episodes Drew uh 17.7 million
viewers uh the second episode uh 18.6
million viewers this scored the highest
rated today entertainment telecast in
six years among adults 18 to 49 and TV's
highest rated comedy telecast on any
night in three and a half years since uh
September 2014.
yeah giant right I mean
um yeah
creatively I'd say it's because that was
a family
talking about jit that families all
across the country were talking about
and they were doing it in a funny way
and that is
like that's it just just
put a pin in it you're done I'm talking
about what people are talking about in a
funny way
um and making sure it's funny right
because it was funny
um
yeah that's it that's that's the whole
job that's all you have to do you don't
have to think I mean that is hard enough
by the way but that used to be kind of
what
Show Business was supposed to television
anyway he was supposed to do was to
kind of bring a funny or scary version
or a heightened version of what you saw
outside your window in here
um onto the TV that's what it was
supposed to do and that's when it was at
its best it was doing that whether it
was telling you a story about you know
people living in a city or telling you a
story a little bit aspirational too what
I was telling you a story about trying
to raise your kids and you know you know
I don't know Rick Richie Little Richie
Petry or something in New Rochelle or
where they're telling you about how how
horrible it is to have a stupid Meathead
hippie son-in-law in your house eating
your food not getting all that stuff
and it could be really funny it's just
that it's also terrifying
um
uh for the executives because they've
been living in you know if you drive to
work every day in a Prius or a Tesla
listen to NPR and you get there it's
like gonna be hard for you to understand
what Roseanne's even saying let alone in
that clip especially let alone like are
you allowed to say it
um
and once you do that
uh then you're not once you once you
once you do that you're not in a mass
media you're not you're not going to get
a 20 share you know you're going to get
a you're gonna get 800 000 people you're
gonna get basically a very very
elaborate podcast which is what most
TV is now just a really nicely done
podcast can you take us back I mean are
you expecting yeah
oh no I was just going to ask are you
expecting a course correction on that
just given the massive number something
like you know there's a whole story that
we'd have to get into as to why Roseanne
got canceled but the fact that for the
brief time that she came back that it
was huge
um
indicates there's a there's an appetite
so do you expect some sort of markets
you correct you'd think
you'd think I mean just this week I
think it's just yesterday the day before
maybe it was yesterday I don't know uh
this week anyway the Connors which by
the way without her is still a hit yeah
yeah
um it's I don't know what season it's in
it's in like it's I don't know Fifth
Season like that
um it has a now has an output deal I
mean it has a second light has a has a
has a syndication deal it's signed
licensing deals signed with Lionsgate
which is a small studio and another
company debar Mercury and Tom werners
one of the people who put it together he
was the original guy behind
um the The Cosby Show and also Roseanne
um and so they're gonna sell it to the
global distribution which is you know
streaming video on demand and other kind
of all the kinds of Rights cable rights
fast rights all that stuff
um and someone's gonna buy it probably
net you know Netflix is going to want it
maybe Hulu's gonna want it maybe oh all
these people are going to want it
because these shows are popular
uh the number one show on Netflix is
suits
right and Suits is a kind of a I know it
has the Duchess of Sussex on it but it
also is like it kind of it was
originally on like the USA Network USA
Network is what they call their Blue Sky
we're doing their Blue Sky period where
the shows were kind of light and funny
but interesting but you could just watch
one and then you could go on your way
you know nobody pays for homework
um and so and I you'd think that they
would understand that in the feature
business right do you remember like
we've just been through a summer
like even last summer when the movie
business is back yeah
um where's the
big comedy like there was there like
this to be like a big Ben Stiller comedy
and a Will Ferrell Comics be like five
or six of those all summer and some of
them were dumb and died and some of them
were great and and the people talked
about him for
they dressed as those characters and how
many Ron burgundies were there at
Halloween after Anchorman came out
um so Barbie doesn't scratch that itch a
little bit but you know the reason we
talked about Barbie so much because
there was only Barbie and also Barbie's
kind of artsy you know has a idea behind
it there was no idea behind the
Anchorman it was just funny can I ask is
it a um is it a failure of imagination
on the part of the studios uh or and
lower you know the creators who you know
ultimately
um you know released their stuff through
this system
um or it you know I mean is is that just
what it comes down to because you know
it seems Roseanne shows this uh various
movies you know top gun Maverick which I
personally thought was horrible didn't
like Maverick I just tested it even more
than the original one but uh what the
hell what's your problem
I got a lot of problems rob you do yeah
especially with the uh I have a lot of
problems with uh you know a movie with
America it's about the is about the
enemy but it can't be named is it Iran
is it Russia is it China is it China
who knows right it's like you know it's
a shadowy republic Breakaway Republic I
don't know you know but no but um is it
I mean so it's not that the audience
it's not that the mass audience has
disappeared it's that nobody is
interested in reaching yeah well they're
terrified of them they're terrified of
them the mass audience if you're in Show
Business you think when somebody's the
master audience all you can think of is
those people at those Trump rallies
people who believe that John F Kennedy
is alive that they that they think that
Bill Gates is inside the vaccine
um yeah that's what you think instead of
thinking just make it funny just make it
funny or scary that you don't have to it
it I have uh a small answer for you and
I then have like a big Think answer
which you can you know take out later if
you think it sounds too crazy yeah we
don't want to insult our audience right
okay yeah right
um the small answer is that um the
really for the first time the people
making
TV and movies
don't really like TV and movies
they're kind of begrudgingly think it's
a kind of okay but it's a little bit I
don't know really like you're all gonna
line up to a movie with a robot you know
robots come from outer space or really
you're gonna go see you know the the
Conor's living room is fake right you
know that like nobody enters and leaves
the room with a joke that doesn't happen
this is a little too good a little too
smart
uh too cool for school really and that's
usually what you can tell we used to say
that about uh when I was doing half hour
comedy in front of an audience that
there's a certain discipline to that
like the audience you can't make the
audience laugh at something that's not
funny
like as much as you want to so that you
can go home you can't so if you write a
joke and you stay there the whole week
and the audience doesn't laugh you got
to cut the joke because they didn't
laugh because it died
um but if you're shooting single camera
no audience there you can just say well
I wasn't going for a laugh there I was
going for some kind of whimsical light
Whimsy something quirky and then moving
on we used to say about people who did
the single camera shows is the great
thing about those is you get to go home
at 5 15. like you don't have to stay
late because what the hell there's no
audience there
um there's no Market in other words
right
so there's that they're too cool for
school but there's also kind of a larger
issue culturally which is this is going
too far so you know which is that we
kind of I mean I try to work this out as
Theory I think it's brilliant so I'm
kind of hoping that it's brilliant but
it may just be dumb so this is you can
tell by whether or not we laugh yeah
exactly
um
uh the smart people
at the top of all of the big
American Industries or World Industries
really smart people in general
have just entered this age of blunder
where smart people are doing just
insanely dumb things that they should
know better because they're just too
smart I mean it takes smart people to
invade Iraq
dumb people wouldn't do it it takes
smart people to build entire Financial
models around whether somebody in
Riverside County can afford to pay the
mortgage on five houses at once only a
smart person could come up with that
dumpers will never do that it takes a
smart person to say we're going to close
all the schools and all the businesses
because we figured out covid and we're
telling you how it's going to work only
a smart person would do that only a
smart person I think would invade
Ukraine
in this age of like only a smart person
would buy Twitter and change his name to
X right like you have to be smart to be
really stupid and so only the smart
people who are running Netflix who are
the smartest people from Silicon Valley
only they could make mistakes this like
colossally dumb only Bob Iger could add
pieces to a business that the pieces
don't belong
so that means tomorrow morning we're
gonna wake up and Anthony fauci has been
named the new head of Disney
well notice how all those people tend to
like support each other because like
right you know like well you know it's
hard like we're really smart we're the
smart people yeah
I I think this freaking Theory right I
like that theory age of blunder
that's that's really great um can you
say as we we end this conversation
um uh can you say something good though
about the well here is the age of
cultural proliferation and the reason
why I bring that up is because back when
you were nominated for your Golden
Globes and let's say we are I was
writing for reason magazine about just
how totally fantastic it was that we
were finally
chipping away at mass culture and it
didn't mean it had to go away yeah but
but you know suddenly everybody could
find their Niche culture too or produce
it themselves and then consume it the
way that they want it are these things
is it does it have to be either or that
like we either have these massive Niche
culture where nobody you know nobody
really sells that many books or nobody
really see maybe the big studios put out
top gun Maverick uh and then you have
the boutiques do uh you know something
great but that's quirky and small but it
always kind of was that way I mean
there's no reason you can't have that
um you know he there's a there's a bunch
of ways for this to work right but one
of the great ways is that you do you're
right you have this you have this you
know YouTube Tick Tock Instagram
experience where there's a lot of crap
on it right but there's some
astonishingly talented people who are
legitimately hilarious and have like
basically doing the same joke over and
over again but they are really really
funny I mean you could put together a
one hour one and a half hour variety
show that would be funnier than SNL just
from those people Alone
um if you wanted to it would be cheap
and you could do it if anybody would put
it on but as long as you have this
system where in order to get your
project funded it has to have an
exhibitor which is kind of crazy
it's not going to work I mean you should
be able as a studio to like flip through
find the funny people or the interesting
people or that good looking people which
happens a lot on these social media
sites just just to use this one example
and uh you know you take their thing and
you try to turn it into a show and then
you try to sell the show somewhere and
sometimes you turn it into a show that
will really will only be kind of Niche
it's going to be weird you know Adult
Swim right or whatever or maybe it's
going to be really this is really really
funny and I why on Earth would this not
appeal to a bunch of different people
um
and I think there's room for all of that
it's just that what you want is you want
exhibitors
who are in the buyers should be in the
position of saying okay we're gonna go
shopping and we're going to buy the very
best content we can
and we have no stake in it like I like
that show I'm going to put it on and I'm
gonna you know I'll come back later I'll
make a licensing deal with you and then
if it's a hit I'm going to come back
later and just kind of nail you on the
term so that I get a piece of it or
something whatever
um
but that's the way it's supposed to work
like it's supposed to work that you
you know it like old show business they
you know it really was that you know
people would get on the bus and they
come to Hollywood and they would get off
the bus and if they were lucky they were
in Schwabs and the you know somebody
said you're gonna be Mr zukor today and
if they were unlucky they were teenage
prostitutes but
although there was probably not much
difference between being yeah
yeah if you're a bad luck you're gonna
meet Harry Cohn today right yeah as they
say you know Lana Turner went into the
studio meeting with I think David
Selznick and she came out to a movie
star yeah
all right we're gonna leave it there uh
Rob long uh we have not seen if uh if
chat CPT or uh Google's AI has updated
anything on you but uh
the glop podcast commentary magazine
Ricochet of course and your various uh
Hollywood offerings if people will
answer your calls after talking about
the industry for an hour and a half the
reason thank you so much for joining us
uh I guess a final point before we say
uh an actual goodbye do you have any
idea when the strikes are likely to end
none I don't know
um
they had a meeting on Friday which was
their first meeting in a while between
the wga and the and the producers and it
was it didn't go that well but it didn't
wasn't didn't end in screaming and you
know chair throwing
um
I I can't see it ending you know I can't
see an ending in December but I can see
it ending like before Thanksgiving
um my optimistic thing would be before
Thanksgiving if it doesn't end before
that it won't end until the middle of
January all right thank you Rob so much
for talking to reason today Zach wise
Miller thanks for joining me this has
been the reason live stream come back
every Thursday at 1 p.m eastern time and
you're going to be uh you're going to
hear us talking to people who's
interesting stuff like you now you you
are just I'm done okay you don't have to
come back next Thursday although you
should